some people asked me to say a few words
on the war in ukraine
i think my words are worth little
but perhaps let me try
i considered doing a long solo episode
on this war i tried several times
but it is too personal for now
to give you context i've been talking to
refugees friends loved ones in ukraine
in russia in poland slovakia moldova
romania even uk
germany canada india china and of course
the united states
some of them crying
or angry
or confused or scared
i'm helping as best as i can privately
and i'm hoping to help in the future by
traveling to ukraine and russia and
celebrating the humanity and the beauty
of the people in this region
this was all set up both for ukraine and
russia trips before 2022
including conversations with scientists
artists athletes leaders and just
quote regular folks
who are equally if not more fascinating
to me
for now it has become much more
difficult but i'll keep trying to find a
way
i was born in the soviet union
my roots are both ukrainian and russian
and today and until the day i die
i'm an american
i'm proud of all of this
i hope to keep celebrating the culture
and the incredible human beings that
make up these nations and humanity as a
whole
we're all one people
we're in this together
that's how i feel about the people of
these nations now let me speak about
those in the seats of power
i condemn all actions of leaders who
played geopolitical games on the world
stage disregarding the cost
paid in human suffering on the scale of
millions
for this reason
i condemn vladimir putin's invasion of
ukraine and i condemn many of the
military interventions by the
superpowers of the world including by my
country the country i love
the united states
that after world war ii has intervened
in over 40 nations with many studies
finding that the united states is
culpable for an unfathomable number of
civilian deaths
i condemn all heads of state
who needlessly wage wars
watching young men and women burn in the
fires they started
i don't understand how humans can be so
cruel to each other
or rather i understand
but i believe in a future world
where this is no longer true
let me also say a few words of what i
hope to do with this podcast
i want to explore the full complexity
and beauty of human nature
i believe each of us are capable of good
and evil and i want to understand how
the mind and the circumstance lead one
to choose the former path or the latter
and i believe conversation is one of the
best ways to work toward this
understanding
for that i think i have to not only talk
to the most inspiring humans in the
world but also to the most controversial
i will speak with many people who i
disagree with
politicians activists ceos heads of
state
with very different opinions on the
world
i will try hard to challenge their ideas
without closing my mind to the depth and
complexity of their perspective and
their humanity
my presence in the same room with wildly
different people will make it easy for
the media and the internet to pick and
choose clips and snapshots attacking me
for being a shill for one side or the
other
i can't defend this point
except to say that i'm a shill for no
one and that i hope you see the strength
of my integrity that i won't be
influenced by any of them no matter how
rich powerful or charismatic they are
like the poem if by roger kipling says
if you can talk with crowds and keep
your virtue
or walk with kings or lose the common
touch
if neither foes nor loving friends can
hurt you
if all men count with you
but none too much
this is a really
really important thing to me that i try
to live by that all human beings count
with me the same people have criticized
me for wanting to have some of these
conversations like with vladimir putin
and vladimir zelinski
and for times in the past speaking about
them without the seriousness the topic
deserves
for this i would sincerely like to
apologize i'm disappointed even ashamed
of my frequent ineloquence on these
topics i will work hard to do better
when i'm joking it should be clear that
it's a joke
and hopefully actually funny when i'm
being serious i should speak with care
and rigor
i've now done many hundreds of hours of
podcast conversation despite my frequent
failures and speaking i hope you know
where my heart is
unfortunately i think people will take
clips of me and use them to attack me
this will happen more and more i guess
there's nothing i can do but send them
my love
in the meantime try to be a better
person and a better interviewer
let me also say
that i like humor
especially dark humor
i like being silly and not taking myself
seriously i will keep taking risks with
that
all with the goal of having fun and
celebrating humanity at its most absurd
and most beautiful
i will occasionally
dress up
in strange and weird outfits to
celebrate the absurdity of life
i will hang out break bread and joke
with all kinds of people
i don't have to agree with them to laugh
with them in order to escape for brief
moment the tension the conflict the
hatred in the world
humor just might save this little
chaotic little civilization of ours
i love the ukrainian people
i love the russian people and of course
i love my fellow americans californians
and midwesterners new yorkers and texans
i love humans i love life and i want to
share that love with others with you
if i mess it up i'm really really sorry
i'm trying my best i have no agenda and
no one telling me what to do i feel like
the luckiest guy in the world to have
all these opportunities and i'm deeply
grateful to be alive and to share that
joy with other amazing people around me
thank you for your support
for all the love you've sent my way i
will work my ass off to not disappoint
you i love you all
you